Haley Shepherd is a student at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School where the
shooting occurred she was trapped in a
classroom the SWAT team struggled to get
her out
Haley joins us tonight Haley thank you
for coming on to tell us what you
experienced today the last 20 minutes of
class there is a fire drill but it was
really weird right away because we had
just had one this morning
so everyone already knew that so I had
either pulled it or that it set off and
it couldn't have been ringing for more
than five minutes
no like more than two minutes because by
time I had reached the stairwell it was
it already stopped and everyone's kind
of stood there not knowing exactly what
to do and just kind of looked around
until we heard three or four just loud
bangs and everyone who was going down
the stairs just ran back up and about
like I want to say over a hundred
students just trying to run into a
classroom and shut the door there is
kids in my class just like running to
the corners like jumping over desks
trying to get behind the teacher's desk
and like it was a mess was the teacher
in the room my teacher actually wasn't
there today we had a sub and you could
tell he didn't really know what to do
okay and like at first we thought it was
some kind of messed up drill going on
but then we started to smell stuff like
smoking gunpowder and our parents were
calling us and kids so I was like
freaking out and calling everyone but
then other kids were rushing them to be
quiet and like it seemed like we were
there for hours but just not knowing
anything or what was going on and only
hearing the sirens outside did you lock
the door the door was already locked did
you have your phone with you yeah like
my very first instinct was to like take
a video of the like the sound and send
it to my
and tell them that I'm okay and was in a
classroom did they respond yeah almost
immediately what did they say well well
then we're just very confused and asking
me if I was okay and where I was and
what building I was in and if I knew
what was going on I not just keep
talking to them no matter what oh that
is how soon you text them while the
shooting was going on and they texted
you back I mean they must have just been
yes panicked
what was your reunion like with your
parents well as soon as I left the
school they had us across the street and
they kept turning us around and like I
was on the phone with my mom trying to
figure out where she was but it was
dying and she said that she was going
towards the end of Park jogger parkland
aisles and as soon as I saw her I just
ran to her and my dad ran and my little
sister was there and we were all just
like crying and hugging each other ah
that's an emotional just emotion was
thinking about that so you were led out
of the classroom and out of the school
by a SWAT team what did you see on your
way out
I tried not to look but there was blood
and gunpowder and bodies just all over
the place like we were stepping over
puddles of blood and just trying not to
look
so all the students in the class that
you were in got out safely is that
correct I'm pretty sure yes all the kids
that were in the class with me when the
door was shut
are safe had you heard of the shooter
you familiar Cola screws that you've
heard that name before no I've never
heard his name I've never met him or
anything like that he's a complete
stranger to me he was expelled from your
school you don't know why no interesting
how finally Hayley have you talked to
your classmates since you left the
school how are they doing my one of my
best friends was there with me the whole
time from the staircase to the classroom
to leaving the school and I've been
we've been checking up on each other and
both of us just like can't wrap our
heads around what exactly happened yeah
it just doesn't feel real and how she
doesn't feel safe I bet she does and I
think a lot of people watching can
identify with your parents and I'm
grateful that must be that you're back
and we are - Thank You Hayley for that
of course